[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
a staggering number of people have made
sexual abuse claims against the boy
scouts of america
ahead of today's deadline to come
forward the more than 82 thousand
alleged victims spanned generations as
young as nine years old
as old as 95. the number of accusations
is even greater than those against the
roman catholic church in the u.s
the boy scouts filed for bankruptcy
protection before settling
these abuse cases errol barnett has the
story of one man
who says his nightmare lasted for years
i was there five minutes before he
unzipped my sleeping bag had his hand
down my pants gil gale was just
11 years old when he says a scout leader
first assaulted him
during a camp out in alabama several
years later he says
another scout leader violently assaulted
him when he was around 13 years old
you raped me and i can tell you that i
struggled with drugs and alcohol until i
was 32.
and it also caused you know i
took a couple of swings at suicide i was
just in so much pain
gail is one of thousands who are
currently accusing members of the boy
scouts of america of sexual abuse
this may be the largest child sexual
abuse scandal in
certainly america and maybe the world
michael fowle represents over a thousand
former boy scouts
the problem it was not a few bad apples
wasn't a number of mistakes but
obviously a systematic failure
on the part of the boy scouts from from
top on down
the organization says it intends to set
up a victims compensation fund
and said in a statement quote we are
heartbroken that we cannot undo their
pain
adding that they are committed to
working as expeditiously as possible
to provide survivors of abuse with
equitable compensation
if we can somehow
make the price the boy scouts pay
so incredibly painful that systematic
changes can happen that will ensure it
never happens to anyone else
i think all 80 000 of us would settle
for that
now mr fowle and the other attorneys we
spoke with say they expect to hear from
a yet
more former scouts each of them are
their own painful stories before the end
of
the day today is the filing deadline
outside advisers will then review the
82 000 plus allegations tony
that process alone of just looking at
all these claims
could take years all right earl thank
you very much